protesters are back in the streets
blocking roads across Lebanon they're
trying to revive the momentum of a
leaderless uprising against the
political class that began almost four
months ago demonstrations haven't
stopped since but they have been getting
smaller the Lebanese army has been a
little bit and and the Lebanese Forces
has been a little bit aggressive you
know and trying to distinguish this this
revolution and this uprising and we
cannot talk anymore to the political
system and to this regime because they
have not heard us they're not heard what
you're saying for the past 90 days
demonstrators say the governing elite
has ignored their calls for change and
are fighting amongst themselves for
seats in the next cabinet instead of
dealing with the near economic collapse
today with our friends my cousin my all
together okay here we don't have our
rights in this country
we pay what we don't have they take they
don't give we pay two bills for
electricity and we don't have
electricity from 30 years okay we need
water many Lebanese accused those who
have been in power for three decades of
mismanagement and corruption a week of
anger that's how protesters are calling
their latest action against the ruling
authorities they say their message is
clear we haven't given up and we aren't
going away
protesters marched towards the home of
prime minister-designate Hassan diem to
protest against the delay in forming a
government independent of political
parties
it seems that Deb's cabinet line up
fulfills that demand but it is believed
he's no longer wanted by the ruling
alliance that appointed him Manila says
there was a misunderstanding from the
start the political parties were never
going to agree to a purely technical
that is not realistic they weren't going
to give up power especially in light of
regional developments anger is growing
so is inflation the local currency is
devaluing public and health services are
failing
Hassan dieppe is just the victim who
wasted time
and will not end up with the government
so now he's as the saying goes dead man
walking protestors have been waiting to
see if government or the political
parties can actually produce something
of value and they have failed scenes
from the early days of the uprising may
have returned but these protesters say
this was always going to be a hard
battle to win yet they're determined to
stay on the front lines Zahra Hodor al
jazeera Beirut